for the rest of us simple folks
we worry about somebody stealing our
password to you you laugh about it
because you know how to do that with
your eyes closed right with
the technology you've created so
nowadays
you know you talk to a certain answer so
where do you hide your passwords i don't
want to really say but i have my
passwords in my notes section and my
phone oh
shoot okay where do you hide your
passwords i write it on a piece of paper
where do you hide your password i have
it on file on my computer
where do you have your password on an
excel spreadsheet right and all these
places you go through
and so now there's a business model for
apps that you put your passwords in and
they protect your password
if it's so easy to break into software
to get my password
how can i trust an app to restore all my
password is there anywhere you
trust to restore your passwords so
let's imagine that i want your password
i'm going to make um a website
for iranian-american fans of atlas
shrugged
and i'm going to send you an email
with a you know free trial discount code
um and you click that the first thing it
says register here
here's your email address put in a
password great you're going to put in
the one that you wrote on the
sticky note on your monitor then i'm
going to take that and i'm going to try
and log into every
every website on the internet and i'm
going to find out where you used that
password before
right and when i get a hold of your
email
i'm going to click on i forgot my
password on every other website on the
internet
i'm going to get into everything so
it's pretty risky right now and i would
say
much lower risk to use a password
manager
i use lastpass
because then you'll have a different
password on every website
you won't even know them they'll be big
and convoluted and unguessable
and you're only going to have to
remember one and so that's
that's what i recommend for most people
because it's a manageable way of
of improving their security and and the
game is really just to not be the
low-hanging fruit
right you wanna you want somebody to
figure out that it's
easier to get into you know
you know somebody else's email than
yours or whatever so
that's the game and in security we have
this maxim which is
you know if you're being chased by a
bear you don't actually have to be able
to run faster than the bear
you just have to be able to run faster
than your friends
and that's really what it's about so i
highly recommend use lastpass or one of
the
one of the password managers and if you
can get through that
and you and you feel like you got it
under control then i
really highly recommend you use
two-factor authentication
especially for your email and your bank
accounts um
and i would caution you if you're going
to do that try to use the two-factor
authentication app
not your phone number your phone number
is a terrible
second factor because it's pretty easy
to take over phone numbers what do you
mean by that
tell me what you mean by really easy if
uh
like look you i have i don't actually
don't know if i agree or not if i have
your phone number
you're basically trusting that nobody
who works for
verizon or atnt or t-mobile
is going to take a call from me saying i
want to port my phone number
to somewhere else right so
you know i wouldn't trust i wouldn't
trust your average
telecom employee any further than i
could throw them
um so i i think uh and we have a lot of
cases where phone numbers are being
hijacked all the time
so i wouldn't i wouldn't count on that
so
so rather than using phone number what
did you suggest instead of there's an
app
called an authenticator app there's one
google makes one called google
authenticator lastpass has one too
and what that does is that works as your
second factor so a factor is
something you know something you have or
something you
are your password is something you know
your iphone is something you have
and you know your fingerprint or face id
is something you are right so you want
at least two of those things to be
required in order to get into your
crown jewels because um because
passwords are
you know i collect them for fun that's
that's a scary thought when you say that
to the average person that you know to
you may not be a big deal to the rest of
us it's a big deal